connaissez l'hôpital monsieur scolaire
d'optique et pas pu me répondre
lequel monsieur le plus proche il est
tombé du 4e note la dans la bagnole et
me dit j'ai mal c'est parce qu'il sait
me dire à la gare de l'est
les flics sont venus ils s'en foutent
regardez dans quel état ils l aient
regardé tous qui sait dire c'est chez
mal
il n'a même pas rempli sa fiche en plus
je peux pas là j'suis pas l'emmener mois
koné venait lui dire pour vous
remplissez pour la fiche monsieur voilà
j'ai mal je mets quoi moi je mets
monsieur j'ai mal regardé la comédie qui
est de la lah au bon vouloir amplifier
la fiche casser les couilles schéma non
mais pourquoi tu ils peuvent pas remplir
la fiche
regardez le regard des navettes vont
vous dire on vous dira le chic et du
maigre regardez j'ai mal même cheval
regardez banon le tout un peu dans le
tour est fini
j'en peux plus là j'en fais deux heures
qui me pourrit la ville tv apple je le
touche au milan
pour vous amener à l'hôpital voilà j'ai
mal il a aucune conversation se fait mal
on va vous amener à l'hôpital dessus en
ces lieux regardez regardez regardez
aïe c'est tout ce qui s'est dit rails
mais elle me fait chier le boulet là tu
vas arrêter deux secondes à deux heures
qui me casse les couilles je vous
appelez comment voilà j'ai mal monsieur
j'ai mal je mette monsieur j'ai mal sur
la fiche moi comment vous appelez je
mène j'aime être non pas des jamais dit
j'aime regarder comment vous à lyon il
est chiant il n'arrête pas de les
menacer de deux cadres comme ça bon là
des grands malades
non mais il est pas malade tu montes
dans quelle mesure il fait pas un peu de
comédie parce que le quatrième mois j'ai
un chat qui ont fait du quatrième trio
l'est pas autant
c'est surtout moins râleurs il sait ni
c'est nier c'est pour faire son
intéressant mais je me demande si l'abus
pas un peu sur les dents là c'est bon ça
coagule là on regarde les il ne sait
quand on parle des liens regardez il ya
quelque chose d'humain dans le regard de
temps regardez regardez voir voulez
qu'on aille à saint louis
guy crise mais ses mains c'est marrant à
voir mais il en rajoute là c'est de la
comédie comédie comédie
allez je vais aller bouffer mois aux
festivités
quand même ouais bah oui c'est normal
est tombé du 4e et une au minimum alors
je voulais déjà et la bordure chance
parce que moi je mange à midi les
ministres déjà des fenêtres et puis il
est tombé du 4e étage oui mais les
urgences je crois que ça peut regarder
cinquième dans le manuel pacotille
on vous a poussé monsieur
j'ai mal c'est tout ce qui s'est dit
dans un fonds dédié mal on s'en fout que
vous a poussée qu'est ce qui s'est passé
là haut tu vas par les ordures ont
déconné ce qui s'est passé là au bon
dieu oui j'ai mal oui moi aussi j'ai mal
moi aussi j'en ai gros sur la patate une
conjonctivite chronique et je ne sais
pas de comédie et je la ramène pas je
souffre en silence moi j'ai fait deux
trois ans jai conjonctivite chronique
vous maison a conduit me plaindre vous
pensez que 20 des radios des trucs comme
ça
bon ben c'est sûr attendu radio faut
attendre et on obligé d'attendre les
malades toi qui fais les radios moi je
peux pas il est déjà midi et demi j'ai
pas bouffer mais garde un petit quart
d'heure ils sentent qu'ils salé aux
lentilles un merci monsieur façon
personnelle val poindre merci à tout de
suite un hall un sandwich merci et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus